sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte damen und herren für umbaupausen
haben wir natürlich im bauministerium
jederzeit großes verständnis
ich freue mich über ihr interesse an der
debatte denn es geht um eine der
zentralen fragen die die menschen
zurzeit umtreiben in deutschland viele
menschen machen sich sorgen wie sie ihre
wohnungen beheizen wie sie die kosten
dafür tragen können und deswegen ist ein
drittes entlastungspaket vorgestellt
worden wo ein ganz wesentlicher punkt
die stärkung des wohngeldes in
deutschland ist das ist in der
geschichte der bundesrepublik die
historisch größte reform des wohngeldes
die jemals geplant wurde und sie wird
dabei helfen dass wesentlich mehr
menschen als bisher diese unterstützung
bekommen um ihre nebenkosten zu tragen
denn wir werden zum einen einen erneuten
heizkostenzuschuss auf den weg bringen
und zum zweiten weil natürlich klar ist
dass die nebenkosten auch in den
nächsten jahren nicht wieder auf das
niedrige niveau so schnell zurückkommen
ihnen dauerhaft implementieren in das
wohngeld und was ganz wichtig ist mehr
menschen müssen in deutschland einen
anspruch auf wohngeld haben dazu zählen
viele rentnerinnen und renten aber
natürlich auch familien mit geringen
einkommen aber auch menschen den selbst
genutzten häusern
wichtig ist dass dieses geld schnell
ankommt wir werden uns sehr sehr
anstrengend und ich setze auch auf ihre
unterstützung im parlamentarischen
verfahren denn die zeit drängt und die
menschen machen sich große sorgen wie
sie in der lage sind ihre nebenkosten
auch zu bezahlen und dabei werden wir
ihnen helfen
aber das was wir jetzt sehen bei der
entwicklung der gaspreise das wirft
seinen schatten natürlich nicht nur im
privaten bereich sondern auch bei der
bauindustrie auch bei der wirtschaft bei
der wohnungswirtschaft und deswegen
haben wir auch in unserem anlastung
entlastungspaket eine unterstützung
vorgesehen für die wohnungswirtschaft
damit sie nicht in liquiditätsprobleme
kommt
der haushalt des bauministeriums den wir
jetzt diskutieren das geprägt von den
herausforderungen in diesem bereich das
eines die frage wie können wir in
deutschland mehr und besser wohnungen
bauen auch preiswerte wohnungen schaffen
dazu habe ich das bündnis für den
bezahlbaren wohnraum ins leben gerufen
wo wir gemeinsam mit der bau und
wohnungswirtschaft aber auch mit
gewerkschaften mieterverein dem
behindertenbeauftragten umweltverbänden
und natürlich den ländern und kommunen
beraten welche maßnahmen wir ergreifen
und wir werden die ergebnisse vorstellen
am 12 oktober gemeinsam mit dem
bundeskanzler und was sie dem plan
entnehmen können ist dass wir jetzt
deutlich die mittel erhöht haben für den
sozialen wohnungsbau
25 milliarden stehen zur verfügung und
als einem weiteren anreiz um zu
investieren dem bereich des wohnungsbaus
haben wir auch die afa von 2 auf 3
prozent erhöht und ich habe mich mit
christian lindner verständigen können
dass das bereits zum ersten juli 23
passiert
[Applaus]
wir werden konzipieren eine
neubauförderung um zu unterstützen den
bau von klimafreundlichen wohnhäusern
aber natürlich auch um familien bei
ihrer eigentumsbildung zu unterstützen
dafür stehen zurzeit eine milliarde euro
aus dem ktf für unser haus zur verfügung
wir werden im nächsten jahr auf den weg
bringen eine unterstützung für junge
menschen die brauchen
studentenwohnheimen die brauchen aber
auch azubi wohnheime und hier werden wir
noch mit den ländern eine besondere
vereinbarung ein besonderes programm auf
den weg bringt und wir nehmen auch jene
in dem sie keine wohnung haben wir
werden starten die arbeit am nationalen
aktionsplan zur bekämpfung der
obdachlosigkeit
ergänzt werden muss das natürlich auch
um maßnahmen andra des sources denke nur
etwa an die mietrechtlichen regelungen
die wir vorhaben im bereich des
justizministeriums wichtig ist dass wir
modernisieren dass wir die produktivität
der deutschen bauwirtschaft
unterstützen und da is building
information modeling die digitalisierung
des kompletten bereich ist eine wichtige
maßnahme aber natürlich müssen wir bei
allen bereichen des neubaus auch immer
den klimaschutz mit denken wir haben
eingeführt das qualitätssiegel
nachhaltiges gebäude und es beginnt sich
im markt durchzusetzen weil es hat einen
breiteren ansatz der nicht alleine nur
fokussiert auf die energieeffizienz
sondern den lebenszyklus des gebäudes
ins betracht nimmt aber auch die
materialien bewertet nach ihrer co2
bilanz und das hat ganz wunderbar auch
zu unserer in erarbeitung befindlichen
holzbau initiative wo ich auch noch mal
danke sagen an das
bundeslandwirtschaftsministerium für die
gute kooperation denn die frage ist wie
wir unseren wald nachhaltig
bewirtschaften so dass er auch für die
bauwirtschaft zur verfügung steht
unsere steht in kreativ und müssen sich
anpassen an den klimawandel hier auch
nochmal dank an den bundestag für das
programm zur anpassung urbaner räume an
den klimawandel
damit können wir mehr
frischluftschneisen finanzieren
wasserflächen so wichtig aber natürlich
auch mehr grün in der stadt
insgesamt ist die städtebauförderung mit
790 millionen euro auf einem hohen
niveau und hier setzen wir auch bei
allen maßnahmen die finanziert werden
auf einen klimaschutz denn wichtig ist
dass unsere städte auch in zukunft orte
sind wo man gerne hingeht um mit einer
hohen aufenthaltsqualität und dass wir
auch die gefahren in den blick nehmen
und die ihnen vorbereiten sei es nun zb
starkregen ereignisse oder hitze im
sommer und ganz wichtig ist viele
sportvereine die hat machen sich große
sorgen auch über ihre nebenkosten und
natürlich ist die co2 bilanz
insbesondere von schwimmbädern eine
schlechte deswegen danke ich auch noch
mal im deutschen bundestag dass er die
unglaubliche summe von 476 millionen
euro auf den weg gebracht hat und dieses
geld diese 476 millionen euro sie stehen
für die sportvereine zur verfügung sie
stehen für jugendeinrichtungen und
kultureinrichtungen zur verfügung das
geld kann aktuell beantragt werden die
projektskizzen können in meinem haus
geschickt werden
und dieses bauministerium weiß um die
große kraft der städte aber auch um die
transformations- aufgaben der steht das
heißt die organisierung sei es die
verkehrswende die bau wende aber
natürlich auch die wärme wende das sind
alles herausforderungen die bewältigt
werden müssen und zwar nicht nur bei uns
in deutschland sondern weltweit und
deswegen haben wir den g7 track das
erste mal gestartet und ich bin froh
dass auch ein japanischer kollege
angedeutet habe dass er ihn weiterführen
will und nächste woche treffen sich
erstmals um 757 auch die
stadtentwicklungs ministerinnen und
minister in meiner heimatstadt potsdam
um genau die fragen zu bearbeiten wie
schaffen wir es dass unsere städte sich
an den klimawandel anpassen aber dass
sie auch resilient und integrativ sind
und ein wichtiger punkt in meinem
bereich ist natürlich auch die
transformation im bereich des bauens
hier passiert viel eine frage ist wie
warum wir effizient wie bauen wir auch
flächen sparen aber natürlich auch wie
schaffen wir es die produktivität
deutlich zu erhöhen es gibt ja bronson
die sind da schon ganz ganz weit vorne
was die industrielle produktion ihrer
produkte angelangt im baubereich ist man
da häufig noch sehr in der manufaktur
unterwegs aber hier ist es notwendig
dass wir aus dem bereich des so hering
borns des modu ladens aus einem kleinen
bereich wirklich einen großen machen
deswegen unterstützen wir auch hier die
bauforschung ist wir sind jetzt gerade
sehr viele firmen auch unterwegs sich zu
gründen um in größenordnung auch sehr
geld zu bauen und wir werden auch ein
bündnis für bezahlbares wohnen die
regelung mit den ländern besprechen die
es braucht damit man auch in
größenordnung in deutschland serie bauen
kann herz lindern
bundesbauminister ein klarer gallwitz
hat mir zum einzelplan und natürlich
auch zu ihren politik vorhaben
gesprochen
jan marco luczak spricht jetzt für die
unionsfraktion
frau präsidentin meine sehr verehrten
kolleginnen und kollegen unser land geht
momentan durch eine schwere krise die
inflation galoppiert die preise für
lebensmittel für strom und gas steigen
und steigen die menschen sind
verunsichert und viele unternehmen sind
jetzt schon in ihrer existenz bedroht
und diese entwicklung die macht
natürlich auch vor der bau branche nicht
halt schon die allgemeine
preisentwicklung ist mehr als
beängstigend bei den baukosten ist
allerdings dass die noch viel viel
stärker steigen holz zum beispiel hat
sich binnen jahresfrist um 60 prozent
verteuert betonstahl um die hälfte und
wenn man mal die letzten zwei jahre in
den blick nimmt ist der baupreisindex um
rund ein viertel gestiegen und das hat
ganz unmittelbare auswirkung auf die
menschen die faz hat heute getitelt
harte landung für die branche die party
am bau ist vorbei und das bedeutet ganz
konkret dass junge familien zum beispiel
ihre grundstücke zurückgeben können weil
sie sich ihren traum vom eigenheim nicht
mehr leisten können aufträge werden
reihenweise storniert projekte
zurückgestellt oder gleich ganz
gestrichen und besonders dramatisch
stellt sich die situation beim
wohnungsneubau ganze 18 prozent ist der
auftragseingang
zurückgegangen und dennoch frau
ministerin halten sie ganz unberührbar
an ihrem ziel fest 400.000 neue
wohnungen zu bauen in der branche
schüttelt man über diese
vogel-strauß-politik nur noch den kopf
das hat schon etwas von
realitätsverweigerung aber ich sag mal
so politik fängt doch mal mit dem
betrachten der realität an nur dann kann
man auch die richtigen
schlussfolgerungen ziehen und dass sie
die realität nach wie vor verweigern das
sieht man an diesem haushalt dafür ist
der beste belegt stadt stabile
rahmenbedingungen statt einer in der
höhe angepassten und verlässlichen
förderkulisse sucht man hier alles
vergebens diese chance ist verpasst
stattdessen ist der haushalt
ambitionslos lückenhaft und ersetzt vor
allen dingen auch falsche akzente
bewährte programme die wir gehabt haben
städtebauförderungen altersgerechter
umbau neubauförderung
sie sind zusammen gestrichen wurden oder
gerade mal auf unseren druck als unions
fraktion auf das nötigste aufgestockt
wurden neue programme mit denen sie
vielleicht auch neue akzente hätten
setzen können fehlanzeige die gibt es
dort nicht ich meine ich kann es
irgendwie verstehen von goebbels dass
sie ein paar anlaufschwierigkeiten auch
haben das ist ein neues thema das sind
große herausforderung und das haus muss
natürlich auch erst mal aufgebaut werden
aber dennoch sie sind jetzt neun monate
in der regierung und man hat den
eindruck sie sind immer noch in der
orientierungsphase in der
immobilienwirtschaft wird man die klage
dass ihnen ansprechpartner im haus
vielen anfragen bleiben monate lang
unbeantwortet und ein organigramm was er
mit blick auf die transparenz sicherlich
auch ganz wünschenswert wäre das gibt es
bis zum heutigen tage immer noch nicht
das ist unzureichend das wird der größe
der aufgabe nicht gerecht aber
immer sage einer hat sich ganz
offensichtlich sehr gut eingearbeitet
robert habeck der gibt nämlich im
kabinett beim thema bauen und wohnen den
ton an nur leider macht er das mit
ziemlich fatalen folgen mehrmalige
förderstopps totale verunsicherung
einbrechenden neubauzahlen darüber kann
man nur den kopf schütteln was er dort
macht das ist natürlich jetzt ganz
sinnvoll und durchaus auch ein folgt
willig würden jetzt wahrscheinlich sagen
aber die neubauförderung die haben wir
jetzt nur ins bundesbauministerium
reingeholt ja das ist auch gut ist
unterstützen wir auch aber angesichts
dieser neuen zuständigkeit haben sie
ganz offensichtlich vergessen dafür auch
die notwendigen finanzmittel
bereitzustellen der mich bei den
verhandlungen was in welcher höhe
zukünftig gefördert wird da hat sich
nämlich wieder robert habeck
durchgesetzt die 14 milliarden euro
sollen es insgesamt an mitteln geben 13
milliarden davon gehen ins
wirtschaftsministerium für die sanierung
und nur eine milliarde euro steht für
den neubau zur verfügung steht also 13
zu eins vorweg ich finde das ist
ziemlich unbefriedigende bilanz
und
man nach daher auch eine ziemliche eine
fundamentale verschiebung der
prioritäten im koalitionsvertrag zum
beispiel hieß es noch im wohnungs
kapiere das bezahlbarkeit des wohls an
der ersten stelle kommt das klimaneutral
erst an der zweite also der bau neuer
wohnungen der war priorisiert die
reihenfolge hat sich jedenfalls immer
die finanz die verteidigung am lenker
ganz offensichtlich geändert und ich
finde das ist natürlich ein zielkonflikt
klimaschutz auf der einen seite neubau
bezahlbarkeit auf der anderen seite das
ist eine aber so wie sie den auflösen
nämlich total einseitig zugunsten des
klimaschutzes das wird der aufgabe die
sie haben als bau ministerin nicht
gerecht oder sonst hat man den eindruck
der koalitionsvertrag erzählt offenbar
nichts mehr sie kündigen da durchaus ja
einige sinnvolle instrumente an
eigenkapital ersetzen darling
tilgungszuschüsse zinsverbilligung beim
eigentumserwerb freitag bei der
grunderwerbsteuer was ist daraus
geworden nichts nada niente im haushalt
findet sich dazu nur gähnende leere
keine einzige ansatz ist dazu zu finden
wenn es konkret wird bei der
eigentumsförderung wenn es konkret wird
den menschen den traum von den eigenen
vier wänden zu ermöglichen liefert diese
regierung nichts die fdp hat alle im
stich gelassen wir hatten ja ein
bisschen hoffnung aber da gibt's auch
sie sich keine kraft mehr bei ihnen
vorhandenen
frau ministerin die immobilienwirtschaft
und auch viele bauwillige familien
10.000 sind unser sind dass in unserem
land die können nicht länger warten auf
ein arbeits fähiges bauministerium und
wir haben ein hohes interesse daran dass
20 23 nicht wieder ein verlorenes jahr
für den bau wird und deswegen ist es für
uns wichtig und fordern sie auch ob er
sie auch auf wir brauchen in dieser
krise eine starke fürsprecherin am
kabinettstisch die auch mal auf den
tisch haut und den ehrgeizigen zielen
dann endlich auch taten folgen lässt
statt deren preisen und der
verunsicherung müssen endlich die
neubauzahlen steigen meine damen und
herren und deswegen frau ministerin
fordern wir sie auf seien sie
selbstbewusst setzten sie sich im
kabinett gegen robert habeck durch
sorgen sie für planungs und
investitionssicherheit schaffen sie eine
verlässliche förderkulisse stellen sie
die notwendigen mittel bereit für neubau
und für die eigentums werbung sorgen sie
für die freibeträge machen sie keine
energiesparverordnung die alles nur noch
komplizierter und teurer machen und am
ende wenig bringen und wenn sie diesen
weg gehen frau ministerin dann stehen
wir ihnen als unionsfraktion der arm zur
seite und helfen auch wenn es mit robert
habeck mal wieder klar vielen dank
vielen dank herr kollege
jan marco luczak kritisiert hier unter
anderen die fehlenden informationen zum
ministerium und tatsächlich wer sich die
abteilung und die aufgaben im
ministerium anschauen möchte kriegt nur
die information dass das ministerium
über die entwicklung und den aufbau
dieses ministeriums informieren werde
wir sind gespannt ob das bei der zweiten
lesung des haushalts anders ist
und dann mit dem stil von fußball
reportern hier 13 21 ergebnisse oder
sowas verkünden tatsache ist dass
tatsache ist dass unsere minister innen
im kabinett an einem strang ziehen und
eine gemeinsame zielvorstellung haben
von sozialer und ökologischer
transformation
und das
und das spiegelt sich auch in diesem
haushalt wider aber bevor ich darauf
inhaltlich ein gebiet ich ihnen übrigens
gerne an das organigramm des
ministeriums zur verfügung zu stellen
dass nämlich existiert müssen sich
vielleicht mal bei ihrem büro erkundigen
dieser haushalt dieser haushalt ist ein
haushalt der sozial ökologischen
transformation
und ich will das beispielhaft einmal
benennen an den zwei großen
bundesprogrammen anpassung urbaner räume
an den klimawandel und das zweite
programm sanierung kommunaler
einrichtungen in den bereichen sport
jugend und kultur hier wird die kommune
werden die kommunen unterstützt und
gleichzeitig sind klarer schwerpunkt auf
energetischer effizienz es werden keine
fossilen energieträgern dort eingesetzt
werden können und es ist auch ein
programm wir haben gesehen wie wichtig
dass angesichts der dürre ist was die
städtischen räume lebenswerter und auch
gesünder machen wird
und es gibt noch eine reihe anderer
punkte die man auch weiterentwickeln
kann und die wir auch in den nächsten
jahren weiterentwickeln werden ich nenne
hier einmal den holzbau dem wir glaube
ich insgesamt auch eine viel größere
bedeutung in zukunft doch zu messen
müssen und das ist nicht nur eine
ökologische frage sondern das ist auch
eine frage von kosten tatsächlich sie
haben gerade davon gesprochen herr lucas
klimaschutz versus neubau oder sei ein
zielkonflikt das beispiel holzbau zeigt
dass dieser zielkonflikt produktiv
auflösbar ist wir haben den klimakiller
beton denn zur herstellung von zement
wird eine enorme masse an energie
verbraucht beton ist auch ein
kostentreiber und beton das wissen die
wenigsten ist auch ein landschafts und
abend killer denn die gewinnung von sand
den ball für beton produktion verwenden
kann das ist nicht einfach und
wüstensand das wird aus flussbetten
geholt die gewinnung von st zerstört zum
beispiel in meinem bundesland am
niederrhein großflächig die landschaft
und das heißt wir haben die heraus das
ist schlimm rinser mit den leuten dort
und auf der anderen seite wird zum
beispiel in der mündung der schelde auch
nach sand gebohrt und dort wird die
gesamte meeresfauna auf jahrzehnte
hindurch dieses abgang des landes
zerstört da brauchen sie nicht sagen ach
da machen sie sich mal lieber kunde ich
meine damen und herren von der union
und mit diesen punkten machen wir
schluss
und natürlich ist auch hinsichtlich der
strukturellen herausforderungen dieser
haushalt auf dem richtigen weg zum thema
bezahlbares wohnen hat ministerin
geistig schon schwerpunkte genannt wir
handeln dort kurzfristig jetzt mit der
ausweitung des wohngeldes wir handeln
dort auch strukturell längerfristig
mitnahm aufwuchs der förderung des
sozialen wohnungsbaus
ich will an dieser stelle auch erwähnen
dass das eine massive ko finanzierung
der länder ist das sollten wir gerade
jetzt in den auseinandersetzungen die
wir vielleicht auch vom bund her mit
ländern über finanzierung haben etwa bei
den entlastungen sollten wir das
tatsächlich nicht vergessen die länder
haben 2006 in der föderalismusreform
durchgesetzt dass sie alleine für den
sozialen wohnungsbau zuständig sind
haben sogar eine übergangsweise
bundesfinanzierung gekriegt gemacht
haben sie ihnen der hinsicht wenig bis
gar nichts es gibt sogar es gibt sogar
bundesländer frau lie sie werden uns ja
gleich wieder soziale
verantwortungslosigkeit vorwerfen ist
krieg sogar bundesländer die in dieser
zeit als der soziale wohnungsbau in die
verantwortung der länder übergegangen
ist massenhaft kommunale wohnungsbau
bestände verhökert und verschleudert
haben vorne mit dabei das land berlin zu
der zeit als sie die pds ihre
vorgängerpartei mit der spd zusammen
regiert haben die folgen tragen wir bis
heute und es geht darum jetzt sich auf
den langen und mühsamen weg zu machen
das möglichst abzumildern zu verändern
und gleichzeitig die soziale und die
ökologische herausforderung für sie für
bezahlbaren wohnraum für sanierungen und
auch für neubau zu lösen
ich wäre jetzt gerne nochmal auf
struktur des wohnungsmarktes eingegangen
das machen sicherlich meine nach
rednerinnen also ein erleichterter
erwerb von genossenschaftsanteilen
begrüßen wir sehr und wir sehen auch
freudig entgegen der einführung der
neuen wohnung wohnungs gemeinnützigkeit
hoffentlich in zukunft danke für ihre
aufmerksamkeit
vielen dank herr kollege kurt
[Applaus]
installierten ist der kollege marc
bernhard auf die fraktion
[Applaus]
herr präsident meine
damen und herren
laut hans böckler stiftung fehlen in
deutschland zwei millionen
bezahlbare wohnungen und zwar nicht erst
seit gestern
und was machen sie an der regierung sie
verschärfen die krise haben
wohnungsmarkt immer weiter sodass wurden
in deutschland immer mehr zum luxus
wirkt laut mieterbund für die führt die
regierungs gemachte explosion der
energiepreise
dazu dass wir viele millionen menschen
die nebenkosten tatsächlich so hoch sind
wie die kaltmiete selbst wenn er
gleichzeitig ausstieg aus kohle und
kernenergie hat uns völlig abhängig
gemacht von russischen
energielieferungen die regierungspolitik
der letzten zehn jahre ist also direkt
dafür verantwortlich für die hohen
energiepreise die wir jetzt in unserem
land haben und
das wall street journal hat es bereits
2009 10 als welt dümmste energiepolitik
bezeichnet
ihr denn bahn und ihre klimahysterie
haben zu einer immer weiteren
verschärfung von bauvorschriften geführt
so dass sich laut wohnungsbau tag
bereits 80 prozent der menschen die
niete der wohnungen die heute gerade
jetzt gebaut werden gar nicht mehr
leisten können und die und im gegensatz
zu allen europäischen ländern
senken sie die steuern und abgaben auf
energie eben gerade nicht sondern
erhöhen diese immer weiter
zu halten sie trotz der exorbitanten
energiepreissteigerungen
eiskalt an der weiteren erhöhung der co2
steuer zum ersten januar fest und was
ändert jetzt der von ihnen
vorgeschlagene haushalt in dieser krise
für die menschen
rein gar nix denn sie setzen die
nutzlose geldverschwendung der vorgänger
haushalte einfach fort auch in diesem
haushalt jetzt zb wieder das programm
biwak mit dem sie ja schon seit jahren
pfannen brötchen backen in nürnberg
fordert fördern und jetzt auch eine
begegnungsstätte in heidelberg oder
kultur sensibles coaching mit laura in
hamburg und wie sollen denn diese
projekte
wie sollen diese projekte den den
menschen dabei helfen bezahlbare
wohnungen zu finden liebe frau
ministerin
wie soll die denn helfen was tun sie
dafür dass die von ihnen großspurig
angekündigten 400.000 neuen wohnungen
pro jahr dann auch tatsächlich mal
gebaut werden was tun sie dafür dass
ausreichend handwerker und
baumaterialien überhaupt zur verfügung
stehen und vor allem was tun sie dafür
dass es wohnen für normale menschen
überhaupt wieder bezahlbar wird bisher
ist diese regierung einzig und allein
damit aufgefallen dass sie anfang des
jahres ein kfw fördert desaster
verursacht hat und damit vielen tausend
menschen den traum von den eigenen vier
wänden zerstört hat und sonst mit gar
nix
mit ihrer klima hysterie erlassen sie
immer neue vorschriften die die kosten
des wohnens immer weiter nach oben
treiben und mit ihrem ziel pro jahr habe
ich ja vorher gesagt 400.000 neue
wohnungen zu bauen werden sie laut
experten krachend scheitern und sogar
deutlich schlechter abschneiden als es
schon extrem magere ergebnis ihres
vorgängers horst seehofer frau
ministerin stoppen sie sofort alle
ideologischen luxus programme in diesem
haushalt und wirkte sich im kabinett
endlich darauf hin dass die
energiekosten wieder für alle bezahlbar
werden und vor allem eines konzentrieren
sie sich endlich auf die kernaufgabe
ihres ministeriums und es ist einzig und
allein ex anderes dafür zu sorgen dass
die menschen in unserem land ausreichend
bezahlbaren wohnraum haben
mag bernhard war das von der
fdp-fraktion der wohnungs und
baupolitische sprecher nächster redner
ist torsten herbst er sitzt für die fdp
fraktion im haushaltsausschuss
herr präsident meine sehr geehrten damen
und herren im vergleich zur letzten
haushaltsdebatte sind die
herausforderungen im bereich bauen
wohnen leider nicht gesunken sondern
massiv gestiegen und wir merken dass
alle im täglichen leben die
wohnnebenkosten gehen nach oben und ich
bin froh dass der koalitionsausschuss an
diesem wochenende klar dafür gesorgt hat
dass wir eine bremse einziehen und
bürgerinnen und bürger so gut es geht
entlasten meine damen und herren wir
sehen aber auch dass die baukosten im
moment auch nur eine richtung kennen
nach oben wir haben engpässe bei
fachkräften
baumaterialien und auch die
zinsentwicklung die hilft nicht das meer
gebaut wird nun sind die entwicklung auf
dem markt nicht alle von der politik
beeinflussbar das gehört zur wahrheit
dazu aber ich glaube es ist unsere
gemeinsame verantwortung dass wir alles
dafür tun dass das bau nicht ausgebremst
wird und wir bremsen lösen damit mehr
gebaut werden kann
die herausforderungen die wir haben sind
groß dass die wiederum wohnen bezahlbar
zu gestalten bauinvestitionen zu
beschleunigen bürokratische bremsen zu
beseitigen
wohneigentumsbildung zu ermöglichen und
natürlich auch städtebau und
stadtentwicklung nicht zu
vernachlässigen wir haben in diesem etat
nur fünf milliarden euro das klingt auf
den ersten blick viel und ich bin auch
froh dass das wohnungsbauministerium
dazu beiträgt dass in diesem bundeshaus
die investitionsquote wieder auf einem
sehr hohen niveau ist darauf können wir
stolz sein lieb kolleginnen kollegen
wir sehen aber auch dass viele ausgaben
und gelder gebunden sind stichwort
baukindergeld was wir der union
verdanken nichtsdestotrotz bin ich
überzeugt werden wir als koalition auch
in diesen haushaltsverhandlungen dafür
sorgen unsere eigene akzente zu setzen
und dort wo es notwendig ist auch nach
zu schärfen
wir haben am ende als
haushaltspolitik auch eine
gesamtverantwortung jeder von uns hat
ideen wo wir noch mehr geld im bereich
bauen wohnen ausgeben könnten und dann
auch meine damen und herren ist es
richtig dass wir jetzt so soliden
haushalten zurückkehren dass wir die
schuldenbremse einhalten das ist nicht
nur eine frage unserer verfassung an
nicht nur eine frage der
generationengerechtigkeit
sondern die rückkehr zur schuldenbremse
ist eine der entscheidende voraussetzung
um diese galoppierende inflation zu
bekämpfen
wir hören in debatten hier ganz oft dass
ein gegensatz aufgemacht wird zwischen
mehr sozialen wohnungsbau und mehr
privatem wohneigentum
ich glaube das sind keine gegensätze
wir brauchen mehr sozialen wohnungsbau
aber auch mehr privates wohneigentum
gerade in diesen zeiten ich finde wir
müssen politisch alles dafür tun dass
wohneigentum und der s bahn im privaten
bereich nicht zu einem unbezahlbaren
luxus für private person wird
das ist nicht nur eine frage
gesellschaftliche stabilität sondern ich
finde auch die beste altersvorsorge die
man sich vorstellen kann ich freue mich
dass das bauministerium noch im herbst
ein konzept zur privaten
eigentumsförderung vorlegen wird
lassen sie mich noch ein wort zum thema
baukosten verlieren eins ist völlig klar
die teure wir bauen desto teurer werden
die mieten
und deshalb glaube ich ist unsere
gemeinsame verantwortung die wir haben
dass der staat bei neuen standards nicht
dafür so dass staatliches handeln zum
weiteren kostentreiber wird wir müssen
das augenmaß bewahren und die standorts
nicht immer weiter nach oben treiben
im koalitionsvertrag ist der check von
bau- und wohnkosten niedergeschrieben
und ich bin sicher dass dies auch
passieren wird meine sehr geehrten damit
kann ich möchte auch mit einem vorurteil
aufräumen ganz oft ist die rede von
großkonzernen die als vermieter mieter
drangsalieren knapp zwei drittel aller
vermieter der wohnung in diesem land
sind im privateigentum das sind oftmals
eigentümer die ein oder zwei wohnungen
haben und ohne deren engagement ohne
deren investitionen sehe es am
wohnungsmarkt viel viel düsterer aus als
momentan ist meine damen und herren wir
als koalition wollen die herausforderung
angehen wir wollen dass mehr gebaut
werden kann daß genehmigungen einfacher
dass sie unbürokratischer werden dass
wohnraum bezahlbar bleibt unter sich
mehr menschen den traum vom wohneigentum
erfüllen können das wollen wir auch mit
diesem haushalt im jahr 2023 erreicht
und ich bin mir sicher wir werden auch
noch interessante akzente setzen im
rahmen dieser haushaltsverhandlungen
vielen dank
und auch torsten herbst folgt caren lay
die sprecherin für mieten bau und
wohnungspolitik der
linksfraktion
herr präsident meine verehrten damen und
herren die mieten explodieren schon seit
vielen jahren es ist lange keine
seltenheit mehr dass menschen die hälfte
ihres einkommens für das wohnen ausgeben
und jetzt kommt noch die explosion der
nebenkosten und die inflation dazu das
ist eine tickende zeitbombe und ja
vorliegende haushalt reicht bei weitem
nicht aus sie zu entschärfen
schon jetzt müssten die bürgerinnen elf
prozent mehr für das wohnen ausgeben als
im vorjahr und die großen preissprünge
für energie die kommen ja erst noch
reine energie hat zum beispiel
mitgeteilt die preise für gas um 133
prozent zu steigern das hieße für eine
familie zukünftig 3000 euro statt 1400
euro
die entlastungs päckchen der
bundesregierung reichen da nicht aus
ich freue mich sehr dass das wohngeld
reformiert werden soll dass es zukünftig
mehr menschen zugute kommen soll und
deine heizkosten und eine
klimakomponente erhalten soll endlich
mit diesen forderungen beißen wir uns
linke seit vielen jahren auf granit
leider sind die vollmundigen
ankündigungen dem haushalt nicht
untersetzt da stehen ja noch schwarz auf
weiß
690 millionen die ständer das ist
weniger als im letzten jahr also das ist
doch lächerlich
und einen gesetzentwurf zur reform gibt
es auch nicht ich hoffe dass sie ihre
ankündigungen bald umgesetzt werden denn
die heizperiode beginnt bald
mit einer wohngeldreform ist es
natürlich alleine nicht getan viele
menschen werden die warmmieten nicht
mehr zahlen können und dem
entlastungspaket heißt es da eher
lapidar sperrungen von strom und gas
sollen durch abwendung vereinbarung
verhindert haben also ich lese da erneut
an die schwammige formulierung die
mieter innen am ende nicht schätzen wird
oberste prämisse muss es sein niemand
darf jetzt seine wohnung verlieren
kündigungen müssen ausgesetzt werden
zwangsräumungen und gas sperren müssen
verboten werden
das beste mittel gegen die inflation ist
übrigens anmieten stock wo novia hat ja
angekündigt die mieten angesichts der
inflation massiv zu erhöhen
mietervereine berichten dass neue
mietverträge zum teil zu 90% index
mietverträge sind also solche die sich
automatisch an die inflation anpassen
das ist bei einer inflation von sieben
prozent nicht tragbar index mietverträge
müssen untersagt werden
janko regierung
bauen bauen bauen zur maxime ihrer
wohnungspolitik erklärt da muss man
allerdings erklären dass die 400.000
wohnungen die neu gebaut werden sollen
aber nicht geschafft werden im gegenteil
im letzten jahr ist die zahl der neu
gebauten wohnung auf 280.000 gesunken
und viel entscheidender für umsatz linke
ist natürlich die zahl der
sozialwohnungen sie haben angekündigt
hunderttausend sozialwohnungen aber auch
hier sind sich praktisch gebauten
wohnungen rückläufig nur noch 21.000
sozialwohnungen im jahr und wenn wir
noch dagegen rechnen dass viele
sozialwohnungen einfach wegfallen aus
der bindung fallen dann haben wir unterm
strich ein minus von 27.000
sozialwohnungen das ist doch ein
armutszeugnis meine damen und herren
deutschen mieterbundes ig bau haben
heute zu recht vorgerechnet dass wir
angesichts der massiven
bestiegen und kosten viel mehr geld
einsetzen müssten für den sozialen
wohnungsbau sie fordern 15 milliarden
für den sozialwohnungsbau statt ihrer
2,5 milliarden 15 milliarden für den
sozialen und gemeinnützigen wohnungsbau
das fordern die als linke schon lang
und lieber hält guckt wir sind uns einig
jede privatisierung von wohnungen ist
falsch aber wenn wir schon noch
überreden das gehört zur wahrheit eben
auch dass keine bundesregierung mehr
wohnungen privatisiert hat als rot grün
unter gerhard schröder und auch ihre
partei die grünen haben sich nicht mit
ruhm bekleckert bei der gsb
privatisierung in berlin sie wollten das
noch mehr privatisiert wird ich kann es
heute nicht mehr ausführen angesichts
derzeit aber in meinem neuen buch
monopoly habe ich es ausführlich
dargestellt ich empfehle die lektüre
meine damen und herren gebrauchen
tatsächlich keine fonds und konzerne auf
dem wohnungsmarkt was wir brauchen ist
dass von jetzt an jeder euro in eine
neue wohnungs gemeinnützigkeit
investiert wird aber auch hier gibt es
keinen gesetzentwurf und ich kann
verstehen dass der aufbau des neuen
ministeriums zeit braucht aber dass sie
jetzt 300 tage verbringen ohne ein
einziges gesetz zum schutz der
mieterinnen und mieter vorgelegt haben
noch nicht mal zum vorkaufsrecht das
können wir ihnen nicht durchgehen lassen
die mieterinnen und mieter können nicht
länger warten dass monopoly muss beendet
werden
deutliche kritik von caren lay hier an
der arbeit der bundesbauminister
nächster redner ist uwe schmidt aus der
spd-fraktion
ministerin neuen kolleginnen und
kollegen der frau leide also wir gucken
alle mit sorge auf die entwicklung
großer der weggenommen auch verstärkt
henry maske die entwicklung am
wohnungsmarkt sehen wir alle mit großer
sorge also ich sehe es noch mal fernab
darüber ein buch zu schreiben das an
sich schon gemacht also die mieten
werden vielerorts immer teurer und sind
damit für viele menschen
finanziell einfach nicht mehr zu stellen
das wissen wir ja schon seit langem vom
wohneigentums werthmann ganz zu
schweigen
einige metropolen und sie kommen ja auch
aus berlin wissen sie was das
mittlerweile kostet aber die
erstellungskosten haben eigentlich
nichts mehr mit den eigentlichen
verkaufspreisen zu tun das gehört ja
auch zu weiter zu jetzt kommen auch die
energiekosten krise dazu viele haushalte
werden voraussichtlich im winter mit
hohem nach und abschlagszahlung
konfrontiert seien auch menschen mit
normalem einkommen
stoßen damit an ihre finanziellen
grenzen und ihre leistungsfähigkeit für
die spd bundestagsfraktion steht fest
kollegin mey es darf niemand seine
wohnung verlieren solle die nebenkosten
nicht bezahlt werden können da wären wir
schon für sorgen darum haben wir das
nächste entlastungs paket geschnürt und
die gestiegenen energiepreise stärker
abzufedern notwendige maßnahmen mit
einem gesamtvolumen von 65 milliarden
sind ja nicht ganz unbekannt nach dem
heizkostenzuschuss aus dem frühjahr
stellen wir erneut zusätzliche
finanzmittel bereit das entlastet
menschen mit niedrigen einkommen bei
ihren hohen kosten für berufseinsteiger
studierende und rentner diese maßnahme
wird jetzt für die heizperiode september
bis dezember einmalig als 23
heizkostenzuschuss an wohngeldempfänger
rinnen und empfängern ausgezahlt ich
glaube das kann man noch mal zur
kenntnis nehmen die ministerin hat
gesagt zum ersten januar
20 23 wird das wohngeld reformiert war
leider mit ihnen nicht ganz zu machen
aber dass er an ihr festhält reden da
gleich noch bestreiten das sind eine
dauerhafte klimakomponente und eine
dauerhafte heizkosten komponente
enthalten wir werden den kreis der
wohngeldberechtigten deutlich erweitern
zusammen stark das sind wir in der krise
und das zeigen wir auch mit den
vorliegenden haushaltsentwurf für den
einzelplan 25 liebe bundesministerin
gauracs sie haben den einzelplan bereich
einzelplan für den bereich wohnen
stadtentwicklung bau wir sind ja bereits
vorgestellt gesamtausgaben in höhe von
gut fünf milliarden euro das ein plus
von 47,5 millionen im vergleich zum
vorjahr die wesentlichen linien an sie
bereits umrissen natürlich kann der
vorliegende haushaltsentwurf der
regierung die geplanten zusätzlichen
finanzmitteln noch ernährt bilden im
parlamentarischen verfahren werden wir
gemeinsam die richtigen weichen stellen
und die mittel sinnvoll einsetzen das
sind ja auch nicht ganz unbekannt die
herausforderungen sind größer denn je
geworden wir haben uns ja nicht
ausgesucht deshalb werden wir für
wohneigentum aufforderung in all seinen
facetten vor linke zusammen stark
bedeutet bezahlbares wohneigentum zum
beispiel für junge familien mit normalen
einkommen statt rendite für große
immobilienprojekte das muss man ja mal
sehen wer die letzten förderprogramme
für sich genutzt hat den wohneigentums
schütz fighters am werk mehrfach
festgestellt da müssen wir auch noch
einige hürden abbauen wir werden
möglichkeiten wie eigenkapital ersetzen
die darlehen tilgungszuschüsse
zinsverbilligung bei wohneigentums
erwerbs schaffen das muss einfach tun
zudem ist das pferd das potenzial von
weiteren flächen für die wohnnutzung
ausschöpfen denn eins ist ja auch klar
boden ist nicht vermehrbar darum
brauchen wir nicht nur neubau sondern
wir müssen auch den bestand sanieren wir
schaffen finanzielle anreize für die
sanierung und den umbau von
bestandsgebäuden und überführen die in
eine nachnutzung das nachhaltig wir
wollen in deutschland gibt es industrie
brachen einige werden heute bereits
anders genutzt als in der vergangenheit
auch viele gebäude können langfristig
nur dann erhalten werden wenn sie auch
neuen nutzungsform finden die pläne zur
nachnutzung aussehen können solche
industriebrachen zeigt zum beispiel
meine heimatstadt das so genannte wert
quartier sowie das gelände der
ehemaligen wollkämmerei in bremen
blumenthal lena ferlemann nicta dass
kinder oder das tabak quartieren
woltmershausen das hat ja auch gerade in
der nachnutzung zugeführt dort werden
die industriebrachen zu baden und
lebendigen quartieren mit einem
vielfältigen nutzungsmix
weiterentwickelt wohngebäude mit
sozialen wohnanteil kultur und
bildungseinrichtung büro gewerbe
einzelhandel in ganz deutschland gibt es
solche flächen da müssen wir gucken dass
über die verbilligung richtlinie der
bima zugriff der kommunen darauf
bekommen um dann natürlich auch in
billige grundstücke verbindlich zum
verkauf an die gemeinden beziehungsweise
kommunen darauf sozialwohnungen stehen
das müssen wir möglich machen auf diese
weise haben die kommunen eine
zusätzliche möglichkeit auch diese
flächen sind vor nach zu nutzen die
länder und gemeinden müssen von ihrem
gesetzlichen vorkaufsrecht an
grundstücken verstärkten gebrauch machen
können und durch umwidmung
baugrundstücke für genossenschaftlichen
wohneigentums erwerb schaffen das
gelebte nachhaltigkeit gerade vor dem
hintergrund von bau preissteigerungen
und energiekosten explosion sind flächen
geben da klappt das hier in wohnungsbau
und andere eben nicht aber das müssen
sie gemeint sich vor ort anschauen die
karriere begebenheit all diese projekte
wenn wir mit entwickeln und dafür auch
die notwendigen haushaltsmittel im
parlamentarischen verfahren
mittelfristig bereit stellen wir werden
die rahmenbedingungen so ausgestalten
dass solche notwendigen maßnahmen für
den sozialen zusammenhalt über die
vorhandenen förderprogramme des bundes
laufen können auch hier müssen wir die
planungs und genehmigungsverfahren
erheblich beschleunigen ein kfw
förderprogramm zum erwerb von
genossenschaftsanteilen für selbst
genutzten wohnraum der kollege hat
sperrt ihn schon gesagt steht in den
startlöchern und das werden wir auch
gemeinsam an das unterstreicht unseren
sozialdemokratischen ansatz in der
wohnungspolitik liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen das neu geschaffene
eigenständige
bundesministerium für wohnen
stadtentwicklung bauwesen ist jetzt
arbeitsfähig dafür haben wir in diesem
jahr gesorgt bauen wohnen und
stadtentwicklung haben nun endlich den
stellenwert erhalten den sie verdienen
nun muss es darum gehen dass wir die
dinge ins laufen bekommt das wird uns im
parlamentarischen verfahren beschäftigen
bedanke mich freue mich auf die
zusammenarbeit
[Applaus]
[Musik]
zum etat 25 einzelplan 25 michael
kießling spricht jetzt für die
unionsfraktion
sehr geehrter herr präsident sehr
geehrte frau ministerin wehrte kollegen
kollegen wir stehen vor großen
herausforderungen der aktuellen lage und
vor gross noch größeren zielen der
koalition geliefert wurde etwas wenig in
der letzten zeit teilweise auch gar
nichts sehr geehrter ministerin und
sergej schmidt ich glaube müssen
schaffen dass man nicht mehr leute in
das wohngeld bringen sollen wir dass man
die leute ermächtigen selber für den
lebensunterhalt zu sagen ich glaube
dieser voraussetzung dass wir sagen
müssen wir niemand arbeitet er muss auch
sein lebensunterhalt auch dafür
bestreiten können das gilt auch zu
führen so gehts auch in der
bundespolitik zu tun von dem her schauen
wir auch in der wirtschaftspolitik ein
arbeitsprojekt dass wir arbeitsplätze
erhalten und schaffen und dort den
richtigen weichen stellen aber komme ich
später noch dazu der haushalt ist
erforderlich um ein prozent gestiegen
was toll ist es nicht weniger geworden
wobei wenn man sich die inhaltliche
ausgestaltung
anschaut dann ist da doch sehr zu
wünschen übrig weniger für stadt- und
raumentwicklung weniger für die
städtebauförderung stopp von zahlreichen
förderprogrammen zb altersgerechtes
umbauen das erfolgsmodell baukindergeld
wird nur noch ausfinanziert und sonst
ist wenig zum thema eigentumsbildung
eigentumsbildung zu finden anreize für
bauwillige für familien unternehmen und
kommunen ist eine fehlanzeige
klimagerechtes bauen fordern ist das
eine aber müssen es auch fördern die
momentane praxis zeigt dass
der anspruch an klimagerechtes bauen
zurückgefahren wird weil die
förderkriterien ist sie schaffen heute
die sanierungsfälle von morgen
den bau investitionsstau den sie jetzt
in diesem jahr verursacht haben wenn sie
erst anfangen mit der ankündigung erneut
höhere programm aufzusetzen 20 23 die
aber erst mitte 20 23 einzuführen dann
haben sie sage und schreibe mindestens
eineinhalb jahren versucht hat mit einem
nicht funktionieren bauministerium und
wirtschaftsministerium um signale auf
dem bau zu schaffen und für wohnraum zu
sorgen ich habe es richtig angesprochen
die baupreise steigen
wir müssen effektiver im pausenlosen
prozesssteuerung vorantreiben da hilft
auch die digitalisierung der freut mich
zumindest dass sie das verfahren
predigen von menschen und zur
prozessoptimierung
weiter voran führen aber müssen auch
schon dass die genehmigungsverfahren
entsprechend auch beschleunigt werden
das war schön dass in der windkraft
entsprechende genehmigungsverfahren
beschleunigen wollen das bedeutet aber
auch für andere infrastrukturmaßnahmen
und auch im aufstellung von
bebauungsplänen wenn nicht wohnraum
schaffen will brauchen wir auch eine
beschleunigung
die zusammen fast der haushalt lässt
viele wünsche offen setzt viele ziele
ich glaube nicht dass wir es schaffen
können und wenn wir noch die
wirtschaftspolitikerin führen dann ist
sie nicht förderlich um die bau
kapazitäten aufrecht zu erhalten sie
müssen auch in der wirtschaft schaut
also signal an den anblick energie
schmidt auch im bau ein große rolle dass
wir dort entsprechend auch die
kapazitäten entsprechend weiter für ein
fortführen der kws weiter laufen lassen
weil wir brauchen auch die energie im
bauen um auch kostengünstig bauen zu
können jetzt legen dank
langer kollege die linke
nächste rednerin ich kann sie schon
ansagen ist die kollegin christina
johannes schröder bündnis 90/die grünen
und kristina schröders bau und
wohnungspolitische sprecherin von
bündnis 90 die grünen im deutschen
bundestag
[Musik]
sehr geehrter herr präsident liebe
kolleginnen liebe gästen zunächst möchte
ich den dank an meine kollegen bernard
ahl druck und daniel fürst richten die
zusammenarbeit in den ampeln gehen
stadtentwicklung bauwesen und kommunen
und mit unseren haushältern ist
konstruktiv von gewisser empathie für
unterschiedliche perspektiven geprägt
und von einem herzlichen miteinander
der sachliche streit ist von dem großen
wunsch geprägt gute lösung für die
menschen in unserem land zu finden
ministerin geiwitz auch ihnen gilt er
dann explodierende mietpreise
flächenknappheit eine seit jahren
andauernde massive talfahrt beim zur
verfügung stehenden sozialen wohnraum
wohnungsknappheit in ballungszentren
leerstände in anderen teilen
deutschlands
es gibt einen massiven sanierungsstau in
leerständen teilen des landes es gibt
gewisse klimaziele komplizierte
langwierige planungsverfahren und all
das haben sie von ihrem vorgänger horst
seehofer geerbt
die gute zusammenarbeit gibt es auch bei
den ministerien die afa wird vom
finanzministerium erhöht und minister
buschmann hat angekündigt noch dieses
jahr das mietrecht zu reformieren wie
wir es vereinbart haben
der haushalt für 2023 beträgt ganze 5,1
milliarden euro von dem rund drei
viertel der ausgaben investitionen sind
investitionen in die schaffung von
sozialem wohnraum investitionen die
menschen durch das wohngeld und auch
investitionen im gebäude über 1,5
milliarden gehen in die stadtentwicklung
oder in die sanierung von sporthallen
jugendtreffs und kultureinrichtung oder
in die raumordnung auch wenn es
stadtentwicklung heißt davon profitieren
natürlich auch die menschen im
ländlichen raum
was ich noch nicht im haushalt abbildet
weil es erst im vergangenen wochenende
beschlossen wurde das ist eine große
wohngeldreform von der insgesamt zwei
millionen haushalte in deutschland
profitieren werden das sind menschen die
sonst keine sozialen leistungen halten
durch putins angriffs und
wirtschaftskrieg aber ganz besonders
stark belastet sind als grüne freuen wir
uns dass wie im letzten jahr der
heizkostenzuschuss ausgezahlt wird er
dachte man ursprünglich um den
steigenden co2 preis für die menschen
mit geringem haushaltseinkommen
auszugleichen inzwischen ist der
heizkostenzuschuss ein zentrales
instrument und mensch in diesem winter
nicht verzweifeln zu lassen denn die
menschen mit geringen haushaltseinkommen
leben überdurchschnittlich oft in
schlecht gedämmten wohnungen und geben
im verhältnis viel viel viel zu viel für
wärmeenergie aus jetzt muss auch dem
letzten klar sein soziales im
klimaschutz das gehört zusammen
hier werden wir oft märchen erzählt
bezahlbarer wohnraum bekommt man nur
wenn man die baustandards schleift nur
dann könne man den dringend benötigten
wohnraum schaffen und nur dann sinken
die mieten nein der baustandard
schleifen will belastet die künftigen
mieten durch zur nebenkosten der
baustandard schleifen wenn ignoriert die
klimakrise belastet die jungen menschen
die dort oben wohnt ganz zuerst der
baustandard leiten der sagt dafür dass
nochmal baustoffe und nochmal
handwerkerin und nochmal planerin tätig
werden müssen um die klimaschutzgesetz
ein zeiten anstatt es gleich von
vornherein es vernünftig zu machen
klimafreundliches bauen und sanieren
dass ein langfristiges nachhaltiges
konjunkturprogramm für deutschland für
die deutsche wirtschaft und für unser
handwerk insgesamt 14,5 milliarden euro
werden in dieser legislatur in den
sozialen wohnungsbau schließen damit
dass beides funktioniert das mit dem
klimaschutz und mit dem bezahlbaren
wohnraum
die neue wohn gemeinsamkeit sorgt für
neue gemeinnützige akteure am
wohnungsmarkt und liebe kollegin der
union sie schimpfen wir auf den wegfall
der bg förderung lassen uns doch mal die
resultate prüfen allein im letzten jahr
wurden unfassbare 16 milliarden euro
aufgegeben das ist richtig viel geld
haben die vielen milliarden euro für
mehr bezahlbaren wohnraum geführt nein
nein nein haben die vielen milliarden
euro zudem zur einhaltung der
klimaschutz gesetze geführt nein die
bilanz von minister seehofer war
verheerend ich glaube ich glaube es gibt
viel bessere lösung um schneller zu
bauen ganz besonders schneller zu
sanieren um wohnraum durch umnutzung und
durch aufstocken und auch neubau zu
schaffen statt des holzweg ist der
vergangenheit wollen wir mehr holzbau
wir wollen mehr digitalisierung wir
waren der flexibilisierung natürlich auf
dem 1,5 grad fahrt mehr typengenehmigung
mehr handlungsspielräume für die
kommunen bei der stadtentwicklung für
lebendige und klima die soli ente städte
die baugesetzbuch novelle im kommenden
jahr wird das meisterstück unserer bau
und stadtentwicklungspolitik ich freue
mich drauf
[Applaus]
keine hektik keine hektik
hier gibt es noch hilfe für christina
johannes schröder markus böhm spricht
als nächstes haushaltsausschuss mitglied
und afg fraktionsmitglied
herr präsident sehr geehrte damen und
herren die zahl der baugenehmigungen für
einfamilienhäuser ist im ersten halbjahr
2022 um 17 prozent zurückgegangen
baufirmen haben zehn prozent weniger
aufträge bekommen und elfeinhalb prozent
der baufirmen mussten sogar
stornierungen bereits erteilter aufträge
entgegennehmen frau ministerin für viele
unserer bürger ist der traum vom leben
im eigenen haus geplatzt besonders junge
familien müssen ihr bauvorhaben aufgeben
weil sie es sich schlicht nicht mehr
leisten können die inflation ist dabei
maßgeblicher treiber aber statt endlich
an die ursachen für die
energieverteuerung und
energieverknappung zugehen betreibt ihre
bundesregierung weiter
verantwortungslose symbolpolitik
ganze zwei kernkraftwerke für lediglich
wenige wochen weiter laufen zu lassen
ist ein trauriges zeugnis davon und wer
nicht baut und stattdessen mietet wird
von den hohen mieten erfasst und die
kommende nebenkostenabrechnungen werden
für wie viele mieter an deren
wirtschaftliche existenz gehen ihren
koalition hat angekündigt 400.000
wohnungen in deutschland gar nicht bauen
zu wollen es mangelt im moment so
ziemlich an allem was man zum bauen
benötigt materialien sind nicht
vorhanden oder außerordentlich teuer es
fehlt an kapazität bei den baufirmen die
bauzinsen steigen und für herbst wird
eine rezession erwartet und als ob das
nicht schon schlimm genug wäre gibt es
von ihnen klima würde einen unklar und
fördert junge und bürokratische hürden
frau ministerin an eine zielerreichung
von 400.000 wohnungen in diesem jahr ist
nicht zu denken sie ist unrealistisch
und wunschdenken dieser links gelben
bundesregierung
in diesem jahr wurde für
wohngeldempfänger bisher einmaliger
heizkostenzuschuss geschlossen dieser
einmalige zuschuss ist lediglich ein
tropfen auf den heißen stein aber nicht
mal diesen sieht man im haushaltsentwurf
für 2023 bis jetzt im gegenteil der
titel ansatz des wohngeldes wird sogar
reduziert und das vor dem hintergrund
der kommenden kosten frau ministerin
deutschland braucht spürbare und
deutliche entlastungen besonders
diejenigen die jeden euro mehrfach
umdrehen müssen um über die runden zu
kommen im rennen gab es am sonntag die
ankündigung dass das wohngeld
ausgeweitet und auch ein
heizkostenzuschuss enthalten sein soll
die frau ministerin und ihre kollegen
sind zum schneller umsetzen aufgefordert
damit sich viele bürger nicht die frage
stellen müssen ob sie ihn wieder heizen
oder etwas zu essen kaufen wir werden
sie an ihren taten und nicht an ihren
ankündigungen messen handeln sie jetzt
es bleibt keine zeit mehr vielen dank
vielen dank so warnt markus buhl aus der
afg fraktion es gibt ja mehrere die
befürchten aus der baubranche das eben
das kernvorhaben der bundesregierung
nicht umsetzbar ist
lieblings präsident meine sehr geehrten
damen und herren
wenn ich diese altbackenen ob wir sind
an ihm
komplimente die uhr stoppen also wer
diese art bei den reden der opposition
hört die zwingen mich jetzt dazu meine
rede umzustellen ja man kann diesen
haushalt für ambitionslos halten wenn
man die geopolitische lage da draußen
völlig ausklammert man kann diesen
haushalt für ambitionslos halten wenn
man auf ihn schaut mit den augen der
letzten jahrzehnte und das scheinen sie
zu tun wenn man die aktuellen antworten
jetzt sucht und wenn man die antworten
für die zukunft sucht dann wird man
fündig in diesem haus hat und der luczak
wie man erschafft sicher cdu-abgeordnete
nach vier jahrzehnten verantwortung hier
zu stellen und ernsthaft dafür zu feiern
das in deutschland kaum noch ein neubau
ohne den zuschuss von steuergeld
absolviert wird das ja fast die höhe der
sucht natürlich in diesem haushalt einen
weiteren zuschlag für die förderung ganz
vergeblich wer aber eine fortschritts
koalitionsregierung hat die
nachhaltigkeit auch finanziell versteht
der findet in diesem haushalt war es für
sich das doch unsinn was sie die letzten
jahrzehnte getrieben haben und gut dass
wir damit aufhören
ich sage ihnen die zeitenwende ich sage
ihnen die zeitenwende geht auch ab bauen
und wohnen nicht vorbei mir fällt erst
auf ich weiß nicht welche baustellen sie
unterwegs sollten party gesehen haben
letzten erzählte ich habe es nicht
erlebt natürlich brauchen wir jetzt erst
recht andere energiequellen in unseren
häusern natürlich brauchen wir erst
jetzt erst recht anderes material in
unseren häusern und ich sechs monate im
übrigen dass handwerker wieder frei sind
ja keine haustechnik aber an vergaben
für genussreisen schlechtes zeichen im
übrigen kein gutes zeichen aber im
zeichen der zeitenwende und natürlich
ist diese zeiten wenn wir auch im wohnen
zu sehen deshalb verstehe ich manche
rede ja auch nicht ganz denn ich sehe
niedrige mieten angebotsmieten in den
letzten wochen und monaten und zwar
drastisch in manchen städten ich sehe
ein steigendes angebot nicht unbedingt
gutes zeichen in diesen zeiten denn die
400.000 wohnungen bleiben
selbstverständlich ein richtiges ziel
war wie immer noch genug leute haben die
wohnraum brauchen aber deshalb bin ich
bei der energie froh dass christian
lindner angekündigt hat dass wir beim tv
endlich der änderung bekommen dass wir
die vertragsfreiheit bis 30 kwp kriegen
mit wieder strom bei den eigenen strom
endlich vorankommen deshalb bin ich froh
dass wir in forschung und entwicklung
einen sprung in diesem haushalt sehen
weil wir ihnen neue materialien brauchen
wenn wir feststellen dass die alten
materialien nicht verfügbar sind weil
ships fehlen weil 14ct nächster zeit
dann brauche ich materialien mit denen
ich über jahrzehnte hinweg und bauen
kann das ist die antwort darauf und
nicht so ruhige töne
was wir brauchen was wir brauchen und
das findet sich in diesem haushalt
wieder ist die innovationssprung in
bauen und wohnen in den nächsten
jahrzehnten und den produziere ich nicht
mit antworten der letzten jahrzehnte die
produziert mit antworten die richtung
zukunft ausgerichtet sind was neues
material betrifft das neue art zu bauen
anbetrifft ich hoffe dass wir es
schaffen eine groß forschungsinstitution
auch in deutschland zu etablieren die
sich um bauen wohnen kümmert anträge
dazu gibt es die entscheidung fallen in
nächster zeit das würde uns weiter
bringen damit die antworten der zukunft
auch welche sind die über jahrzehnte
tragen ich hoffe dass wir bei den
energieträgern weiterkommen dafür stehen
die antworten in diesem haushalt drin
also hören wir auf die die in die
zukunft schauen und ich die die die
brillen der vergangenheit auch
fahrenschon
dazu beitragen reinhold und zu hören ist
im hintergrund schon klopfen bundestags
vizepräsident wolfgang kubicki macht so
gerne auf das ende der redezeit
aufmerksam
jetzt bernhard daldrup spd fraktion
präsident liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
mit leben das ich schon mehrfach gesagt
und in einer zeit wirklich multipler
krisen klimawandel rohstoffe das muss
sich alles nicht mehr wiederholen und
sie haben auch diese zeitenwende als
koalition reagiert erstens mit den 100
milliarden bundeswehr dass man sich hier
nicht ist nicht unser thema aber mit
zwei entlastungspaket 'nen über ein
volumen von 30 milliarden und jetzt mit
einem entlastungspaket über in der summe
für mit 60 milliarden ich sagte dass
deswegen weil das ist eine gewaltige
kraftanstrengung die diese ampel
vorgenommen hat und manchmal kommt mir
in den kommentierungen so vor was
glauben sie es wäre ein einfaches
geschäft der laufenden verwaltung nein
ist es nicht es ist eine große maßnahme
und viel davon konnten bürgerinnen und
bürgern zugute auch übrigens im bereich
vom bauen von mieten von wohnen und ich
will das mal kurz sagen erstens
marktwirtschaftlich klein von mir das
organigramm des ministeriums das müsste
sich eigentlich machen lassen hätte er
vielleicht auch schon selber kriegen
können zweitens zweitens ich weiß ja
zweitens ich weiß ja wie jan marco
luczak über horst seehofer gesprochen
hat und wie glücklich er deswegen ist
dass klara geywitz in unsere ministerin
ist weil da wirklich was passiert und
ich wette darauf wird
drittels und drittens
sagen michael kiessling altersgerechtes
umbauen schaden beträgt 75 millionen
sich reduziert sondern sie das erhöht
worden viertens neue programme anpassung
kubaner räume beträgt 176 millionen
damit die klimagerechtigkeit von städten
und gemeinden verbessert wird ein neues
programm also worüber reden sie
eigentlich gucken sie erst mal reinlesen
hilft findet jedenfalls also man kann
über diese pakete kritisch diskutieren
nichts dagegen überhaupt nichts dagegen
aber es ist dann kompromiss wo wir eine
diskussion zu lassen aber es nicht
zulassen dass die dinge diskreditiert
werden und die vorschläge und ratschläge
von denjenigen die schon geglaubt haben
im märz man sollte den gasbezug
einstellen oder jetzt auch sachsen sagen
sie sollen morgen wieder aufnehmen die
sind auch nicht so besonders zielführend
das glauben jedenfalls nicht
wir haben uns seitens der spd in dresden
auch dieses paket übrigens vorbereitet
und zwar unter dem begriff sicherheit
geben chancen schaffen und darum geht es
auch in diesem haus art energie geld 300
euro für rentnerinnen studierende und
ähnliches mehr und ähnliche gruppen das
heißt sicherheit geben ich weiß sie
haben das kritisiert strecke bedeutet
sicherheit geben damit die preise
beherrschbar bleiben wohngeld auch zwei
millionen haushalte ausweiten eine
maßnahme die vor einigen jahren noch
ganz abgeschafft werden sollte ist eine
eminent wichtige aufgabe um sicherheit
zu geben damit wohnen bezahlbar bleibt
und die wohnung warm bleibt deswegen
heizkostenpauschale
kurzfristig klimakomponente
im rahmen der wohngeldreform als
dauerhafte bestandteile das alles ich
glaube ich wichtige maßnahme sicherheit
geben auch das sperren von gas und strom
soll vermieden werden ja es ist nicht
notariell im indikativ festgeschrieben
tagen sei aber das wusste ich nicht dass
man das neuerdings sondern als maßstab
an die programme legen soll sicherheit
geben mieterinnen und vermieter
schützenden betriebskosten
vereinbarungen sie überfordern im rahmen
des sozialen mietrechts sicherheit geben
ja den co2 preis aussitzen herz ich weiß
nicht ob das mitgekriegt haben steht in
dem papier um zusätzliche belastungen zu
vermeiden und ich sage ihnen mal wenn
man sicherheit geben will und wenn man
perspektiven anbietende und schaffen
will dann braucht man in dieser
gesellschaft eine klammer und die nennt
man solidarität hier die autos gemeinsam
schaffen und deswegen ist es auch
gerechtfertigt zu sagen es ist ausdruck
von gesellschaftlicher solidarität wenn
von allen erzeugern die nicht auf das
angewiesen sind bei der stromproduktion
zufalls gewinne abgeschöpft werden ob
man das jetzt über gewinnsteuern benennt
oder anders soll mir egal sein aber
jedenfalls privathaushalten ein basis
verbrauch an strom zu einem
vergünstigten preis zu bekommen ist die
rechtfertigung dafür ich würde mich
freuen wenn uns ähnliches auch im
wärmemarkt übrigens gelingt ich glaube
wir behalten bei all den notwendigkeiten
bei den perspektiven im haushalt eben
auch chancen zu schaffen das im auge es
ist eben angesprochen worden wir müssen
der bauwirtschaft den rücken stärken ja
das in der tat war und ich glaube wir
tun das auch an andere an verschiedenen
stellen ich will aber ein paar zahlen
luczak angesprochen hat doch mal eben
nochmal rekapitulieren weil wir im ziel
400.000 wohnungen festhalten
293.000 baufertigstellungen den 20 21
gewaltige bau überhänge im jahre 2022
haben wir in den zeitraum von januar bis
april
124000 baugenehmigungen der rückgang ist
tatsächlich im ein und
zweifamilienhausbau weil die
zinsentwicklung eine dramatische
entwicklung ist die entwicklung die
entwicklung bei den mehrfamilienhäusern
ist gestiegen um 11,6 prozent
das muss man doch auch mal dazu sagen es
hat damit zu tun ein stück weit
jedenfalls dass die mittel für den
sozialen wohnungsbau ankommen im markt
das ist ein wichtiger gesichtspunkt und
das ist deswegen wichtig weil wir zum
jetzigen zeitpunkt wissen dass
mieterinnen und mieter zum mit 12,8
schon in erheblichem maße überlastet
sind also wir haben in diesem haushalt
eine ganze reihe von aspekten drehen die
wirklich zeigen dass wir die zeichen der
zeit verstanden haben und eine moderne
politik für die zukunft machen werden im
interesse unseres landes der investoren
und auch der mieterinnen und mieter
herzlichen dank vielen dank herr kollege
dadurch 5,01 milliarden euro soll es im
jahr 2023 für den einzelplan 25 geben
das ist ein prozent mehr als in diesem
jahr aber die debatten darüber sind ja
noch am laufen
also liebe vertreterinnen und vertreter
der ampelkoalition sie werden uns den
vorwurf schon zugestehen müssen ihre
selbst gesteckten ziele
400.000 neue wohnungen pro jahr werden
sie in der jetzigen situation und bei
betrachtungen dieses haushaltes nicht
erreichen und das ist nicht nur eine
erkenntnis der opposition sondern es ist
auch eine erkenntnis von
branchenexperten und ich glaube
was noch ja da komme ich zu da komme ich
noch zu was noch viel wichtiger ist es
dass wir jetzt aufhören müssen immer
einen rückspiegel zu schauen sie sind
jetzt seit mehreren monaten im amt und
jetzt ist es immer zeit nach vorne zu
gucken und immer nach vorne zu gucken
sondern auch jetzt wirklich mal
maßnahmen nicht nur anzukündigen sondern
auch durchzusetzen und ein eigener bmw
sb haushalt kann sich nicht mehr hinter
zuständigkeiten und vorgängerregierungen
verstecken wir haben das gerade schon
gehört ja wohnen ist daseinsvorsorge und
damit elementarer bestandteil einer
politik die den menschen in den
mittelpunkt stellt und ich glaube da
besteht hier auch groß konsens ich finde
heute sollten wir festhalten die beamte
machen sie sich endlich ehrlich und
korrigieren sie ihre selbst gesteckten
ziele die heutige haushaltsdebatte wäre
dazu eine gute gelegenheit denn die
intern und extern widrigkeiten
zeigen sich im grunde genommen
wir erleben im baubereich derzeit preis
explosion lieferengpässe material und
fachkräftemängel dazu kommt noch ein
seit jahresbeginn herrschendes café
förder chaos selbstkritik gibt es bei
ihnen bei der koalition dazu nicht und
als bedrohliche spitze des eisberges
auch noch explodierende energiekosten
und ich habe auch jetzt in der debatte
bisher wirklich keine wirksamen
antworten zur lösung dieser
schwerwiegenden problem von ihnen von
der koalition gott keine einzige lösung
habe ich von ihm gehört trotz seines
großen etats in diesem haushalt wird in
zukunft weniger gebaut wenn die
bundesregierung nicht viel
zielgerichteter mehr mittel in ganz
konkreten bereichen zur verfügung stellt
dies gilt etwa für die förderprogramme
für nachhaltiges bauen und energetische
sanierung und das voerder chaos und das
bleibt auch dabei das haben wir schon
vor einigen wochen besprochen hat
private und gewerbliche investoren
verunsichert und tut es auch noch heute
und gespickt wird das ganze in der
bundesregierung dann auch an einer
grundsätzlichen politischen
einstellungen wie an den realitäten
vorbei geht und die den menschen vorgang
sowohl und das muss man sich jetzt mal
die zunge zergehen lassen auf
bauministerin geiwitz zu viele
bürgerinnen und bürger in zu großen
häusern und wohnungen ich meine das kann
doch wohl nicht die antwort der
ministerin auf die derzeit drängenden
probleme dieses landes in der bau und
wohnungspolitik sein das kann doch nicht
die richtige antwort zeigen wenn die
zukunft des klimabewussten wohnt hängt
wohl vom energiebedarf und der
energieerzeugung ab und nicht von pro
kopf wohnfläche eine kleine unsanierter
altbau wohnung kann heute
klimaschädlicher sein hat sein großer
aber ich glaube das brauchen wir nicht
erklären anstatt planwirtschaft ideen zu
verbreiten sollte sich frau ministerin
geywitz lieber um ihre ziele und um ihre
baustellen kümmern wir als union geben
falls wir wollen den menschen nicht
vorschreiben wie sie zu wohnen haben wir
wollen eine effektive eigentumsförderung
für neu und bestandsbauten denn auch das
gehört zur weiter zu und auch das
sollten wir heute noch mal betonen wer
heute neu gebaut der baut nachhaltig und
nach hohen standards in sachen
energieeffizienz
und
frauenministerin obliegt jetzt die
undankbare aufgabe für das ein bisschen
bleiben die neubauförderung kriterien zu
entwickeln die den unmut der bauwilligen
nicht nur größer machen als er noch nach
dem abrupten förderstopps in diesem jahr
schon ist doch investitionen gerade im
privaten bereich die brauchen
verlässliche rahmenbedingungen und die
vorräten haben es auch gerade schon
angesprochen ein gesamtkonzept zur
wohnraumförderung die fehlt sie haben es
angekündigt aber das konzept fehlt es
muss jetzt sofort kommen denn für uns
geld eigentumserwerb dient der
altersvorsorge schützt vor inflation und
schafft sachwerte für kommende
generation ich finde das ist wichtiger
denn je in dieser jetzigen zeit
ich kann noch kein konzept zur
eigentumsförderung finden ich bin
gespannt sie haben es angekündigt wann
es kommt
deutlich und das ist glaube ich auch
festgestellt worden
sinken sollen im haus das entwurf die
ausgaben für das baukindergeld und das
ist ehrlich gesagt ein erfolgsmodell
gewesen es ist gut angenommen worden und
es hat gezeigt wie eigentumsförderung
funktionieren werden und wir haben ja
vorschläge gemacht der ansatz den erwerb
von selbstgenutztem wohneigentum im
bestand mit dem programm wo kauft als zu
fördern und dabei auch die notwendige
investitionsmaßnahmen für klimagerechte
modernisierung und sanierung zu
berücksichtigen findet sich bei ihm
nicht wieder in den letzten beratungen
haben wir es getan und es war
vorhersehbar dass sie heute die erhöhten
mittel für den sozialen wohnungsbau hier
feiern werden als koalitionäre ich finde
das ist richtig dass wir etwas für den
sozialwohnungsbau tun nur unter möchte
ich auch in der debatte hier schon
darauf hinweisen in der realität sind
die bundesländer in denen es 2021 ein
anstieg bei den sozialwohnungen gab von
der union regiert auch das sollte man
mal sagen und voller gehenden vorzug
gibt es noch mehrere bundesländer die
von der spd regiert wurden ja ich glaube
aber es gilt auch bei den
bauvorschriften weiter zu vereinfachen
zu beschleunigen und zu erleichtern wir
haben vorschläge gemacht die werden wir
auch in der haushaltsberatung einbringen
es ist daher im sinne aller mieterinnen
und mieter sowie eigentümer 100
eigentümern wenn der etat zu diesem
einzelplan in den kommenden beratungen
noch nachbesserungen erhält
reimann verweist nochmal auf die
sozialwohnungen etwa die hälfte der rund
23 millionen mieterhaushalte wäre nach
schätzung des deutschen mieterbundes
berechtigt in einer geförderten wohnung
zu leben es bringt ihnen natürlich nicht
viel wenn diese wohnung nicht existieren
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
das in haushaltsreden werden ja
tatsächlich viele zahlen genannt ich
werde an die tradition anknüpfen aber
ich verspreche ihnen ohne fußballfeld
vergleiche und ohne vergleiche mit dem
saarland
in der zuständigkeit des ministeriums
liegt ja relativ viel ich werde mich auf
die wohnungspolitik fokussieren den 82
millionen menschen in deutschland also
alle wurden und von daher ist es ein
thema das uns alle beschäftigen sollte
dazu eine kurze bestandsaufnahme mit
fünf punkten
erstens sozialwohnungen ist schon kammer
heute gefallen die zahl der verfügbaren
sozialwohnungen ist in den letzten
jahren stark gesunken
2002 gab es 2006 hat mir noch über 62
millionen sozialwohnungen letztes jahr
als wir die regierung übernommen haben
waren es noch knapp 1,1 millionen
sozialwohnungen
zweitens mietbelastung da hat karin may
ja auch schon einiges dazu gesagt
letztes jahr guyton 12,8 prozent der
bevölkerung in mieterhaushalten als
überbelastet dh mehr als 40 prozent
ihres
haushalts nettoeinkommens für die miete
aufbringen müssen diese zahl wird
vermutlich steigen und dagegen müssen
wir antworten finden
dritte herausforderung die energiepreise
durch die abhängigkeit von russischem
gas und putins krieg auf die ukraine
sind die gaspreise explodiert allein in
der letzten heizperiode sind die
energiepreise die kosten fürs heizen mit
dem gas haben sich verdoppelt viele
herausforderungen die heute noch nicht
gefallen ist die barrierefreiheit unsere
gesellschaft wird älter trotzdem sind
nur ein bis zwei prozent der wohnungen
aktuell barrierearm
fünftens auch das ist leider noch nicht
gefallen aber trotzdem ein großes thema
die wohnungslosigkeit in deutschland
sind 180 x 180 tausend menschen von
wohnungslosigkeit betroffen und leben
entweder in notunterkünften oder anderen
gemeinschaftsunterkünften dazu gibt es
noch menschen die vollkommen ohne obdach
sind und auf der straße leben gegen
dieser herausforderung müssen wir etwas
tun
und die gute nachricht ist der
haushaltsentwurf 20 23 findet auch viele
dieser herausforderungen auch antworten
ja soziale wohnungsbau wird gestärkt
wie versprochen kommen 25 milliarden
euro dazu das wohngeld wird ausgebaut
darüber soll heute abend viel gesprochen
und herr kießling ja natürlich wäre es
schöner wenn weniger menschen wohngeld
brauchen würden das stimmt deswegen
haben wir den mindestlohn erhöht
deswegen machen wir viele maßnahmen aber
in einer akuten krise zu sagen wäre
besser wenn die leute das nicht brauchen
finde ich relativ zynisch deswegen finde
ich muss man ja reagiert und in der zeit
wo viele menschen bedarf haben schnell
kurzfristig das ändern deswegen ist es
gut dass das wohngeld auch zwei
millionen menschen ausgeweitet wird
wir leben in einer alternden
gesellschaft mit dem kfw programmen
altersgerechte umbau fördernde maßnahmen
zum zwecke der alten und
behindertengerechten anpassung von
wohngebäuden 20 23 werden nach dem
haushaltsentwurf 63 millionen euro dafür
bereit stehen und die letzte antwort wir
fordern vielfältige wohnformen das ist
gerade in ihr oder uns als grüne
besonders wichtig mit dem neuen kfw
programm zum erwerb von
genossenschaftsanteilen
senken will menschen das startkapital
und und damit die hürden sich an
genossenschaften zu beteiligen dieses
programm läuft gerade an und wir werden
die mittel in kommenden jahren weiter
ausbauen
was fehlt noch von den herausforderungen
wir brauchen eine langfristige
veränderung am wohnungsmarkt denn wir
müssen in die wohnungen nicht mehr für
investoren bauen sondern für die
menschen die darin wohnen wir brauchen
mehr dauerhaft bezahlbarem wohnraum und
deswegen ist es so wichtig dass wir eine
neue wohn gemeinnützigkeit einführt die
genau dafür sorgt dass wohnungen
dauerhaft unter dem mietspiegel
vermietet werden dafür fehlt noch ein
bekenntnis im bundeshaushalt aber es
heißt der haushaltsberatungen unterholz
verhandlung deswegen bin ich sehr
optimistisch dass wir da noch was zu
verändern können und das zweite ist der
nationale aktionsplan wohnungs und
obdachlosigkeit wir haben uns im
koalitionsvertrag darauf geeinigt dass
wir bis 2030 dass es in acht jahren
wohnungs und obdachlosigkeit und
deutschland überwinden wollen die zeit
ruft also von daher erwarte ich dass wir
in den haushaltsverhandlungen auch dafür
noch mal geld einstellen liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen die
herausforderung groß wir haben
verschiedene antworten und freuen uns
nun für diese verschiedenen wohnformen
antworten zu finden und auf die
verhandlungen vielen dank
lena karoline und
wir schreiten fort in der rednerliste
sebastian münzenmaier spricht jetzt für
die archivfunktion
sehr geehrter herr präsident meine damen
und herren laut statista ist eine der
größten sorgen der 18 bis 24 jährigen
unserem land dass sie in zukunft
überhaupt noch bezahlbaren wohnraum
finden und diese sorge ist leider
berechtigt denn schon letztes jahr
fehlten knapp 600 30.000 wohnungen in
deutschland und nun verschärft sich die
lage und im kommenden winter das haben
wir heute mehrfach gehört entwickeln
sich die eigenen vier wände also auch
noch zu einer kostenfalle das
grundbedürfnis wohnen ist mittlerweile
zum luxusgut verkommen aber in dieser
legislatur sollte doch eigentlich alles
besser werden noch im dezember 2021
versprachen sie meine damen und herren
von der ampel vollmundig den bau von
400.000 wohnungen im jahr und ein neues
ministerium mit knapp 15 millionen
geplanten personal budget sollte endlich
die wohnungsnot in unserem land
beseitigen also ziehen wir mal nach den
ersten monaten eine kleine bilanz das
einzige was dieses neue ministerium
bislang gebaut hat sind luftschlösser
meine damen und herren selbst ihre
eigenen leute glauben doch gar nicht
mehr an ihre ziele menschen müssen den
bau ja sie vielleicht aber höher der
druck hat sich zumindest die presse so
zitieren lassen menschen müssen den bau
ihres lang ersehnten eigenheims
abbrechen weil die ampel die
kfw-förderung mehrfach verstolpert und
sogar abrupt gestoppt hat so dass die
bauherren vor den trümmern der eigenen
planung sitzen während sie also wieder
mal steuergelder in der ganzen welt
verteilen ist für den ganz normalen
deutschen bürger leider nichts mehr da
meine damen und herren ihr ministerium
frau gallwitz
hat es medienberichten zufolge in acht
monaten nicht mal geschafft einen
funktionierenden telefonanschluss zu
gewährleisten stattdessen fabulieren sie
von der eindämmung des bau von
einfamilienhäusern und möchten aus
klimaschutzgründen am liebsten die
quadratmeter reduzieren meine damen und
herren wenn ihnen schon nichts
ordentliches einfällt dann greifen sie
doch wenigstens unsere sinnvollen
vorschläge auf erstens unser land muss
endlich ein land der eigentümer werden
während die eigentumsquote in der von
uns maßgeblich finanzierten eu ungefähr
70 beträgt liegen wir hier in
deutschland bei mageren 50 prozent der
afg lösungsvorschlag liegt auf dem tisch
wurde von ihnen allen mehrfach abgelehnt
schaffen wir die grunderwerbssteuer für
den erwerb von selbst genutztem eigentum
ab und sorgen dafür dass sich junge
familien deutschland wieder ein kleines
häuschen leisten können
zweitens wir wollen bauen fördern
anstatt neubauten zu verhindern also
bauen sie bürokratie ab und hören sie
endlich damit auf allen bauherren in
deutschland tag und nacht mit neuen
wahnsinnigen klima regulären auf den
geist zu gehen meine damen und herren
und zu guter letzt auch wenn sie es
nicht hören wollen wer wenig wohnraum
hat muss priorisieren also schieben sie
die knapp 300.000 ausreisepflichtigen
ausländern endlich ab die wohnraum
blockieren und die sich hier in
deutschland überhaupt nicht mehr
aufhalten dürfen meine damen und herren
deutschland hat eigenbedarf schreiben
sie sich hinter die ohren und agieren
sie endlich im sinne unserer eigenen
bürger erzielen dank für ihre
aufmerksamkeit
sobald sebastian münzenmaier nächster
redner ist daniel voest er ist von der
fdp-fraktion der sprecher für bau und
wohnungspolitik
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter herr präsident frau
ministerin werde kolleginnen und
kollegen extra für die after wenig wir
machen deutschland zu dem
einwanderungsland dass es sein muss wir
brauchen fachkräfte wir brauchen
zuwanderung und wir brauchen diejenigen
die die wohnungen bauen und ihre
ständige abschiede an die auswahl der
rektor ist unerträglich
jetzt können sie sich mit sich selber
beschäftigen wir machen politik dieser
minister beschäftigen
muss man zur cdu/csu einmal feststellen
das wird ja teilweise unfreiwillig
komisch wenn der herr breilmann erklärt
die cdu csu erklärt uns wie eigenheim
und eigentumsförderung geht dann frage
ich mich nach 16 jahren unter cdu csu
führung der bundesregierung sind weniger
menschen im eigentum als vorher am ende
ist die eigentumsquote gesunken und sie
stellt sich hier her und sagen ihr wisst
wie es geht nein das tut er nicht
ausweislich der zahlen ich mache bei
radlern dass wir beim thema des
wohneigentums noch groß auf hausaufgaben
vor uns haben das ist ja content die die
gesellschaft wollen die menschen wollt
ich will auch wohneigentum ist wichtig
die soziale effekt des wohneigentums ist
nicht zu unterschätzen
und da wären wir auch angehen beim
grunderwerb steuerreform wird gearbeitet
habt ihr eben nicht hinbekommen an
kollege von s p zufolge auch erwähnt an
eigenkapital assets in italien wird
gearbeitet
es gibt nach wie vor das kfw programm
zur zins vergünstigung das sind alles
themen die auf die
wohneigentumsförderung einzahl werden
und die werden deutlich besser werden
als alles was ihr mit multi milliarden
erreicht haben am ende dieser legislatur
wird die wohneigentumsquote steigen da
bin ich mir sehr sicher zweiter punkt
sehr unfreiwillig komisch finde und
hohen
ich weiß dass ich die ampel sehr
ehrgeizige ziele gesetzt hat ich weiß es
und nach dem was wir vorgefunden haben
waren diese ehrgeiz im ziel auch
notwendig aber wenn ich jetzt die redner
der union verstanden habe dann wäre die
richtige antwort darauf und die ziele
sind ehrgeizig und schwer lasst uns die
ziele kassieren und das sage ich das
sage ich euch mal herr ludger breimann
wenn die ziele ehrgeizig sind wenn die
aufgaben schwer sind dann liegt es an
uns hier im bundestag ohne die dort üben
da liegt es an uns hier im bundestag
diese anforderungen aufzunehmen die
weichen zu stellen und dafür sorgen dass
es besser wird und wenn wir nicht auf
1000 wohneinheiten genau das ziel
erreichen wir werden nicht aufgeben bis
das wohnen für alle bezahlbar bleibt bis
die menschen wohneigentum sind und bis
irgendwann die 4000 wohnungen entstehen
so und dazu dazu es ist ja kein
geheimnis die zusammenarbeit in der
ampel macht spaß man hatten viele
pc-spieler es macht ja es macht ja spaß
aber wir sind nicht immer einer meinung
das ist ja kein geheimnis aber in diesem
haushalt das sind wichtige
weichenstellungen drin die lange jahre
gefehlt haben die bauforschung wird
ausgeweitet ja wir brauchen neue
baumaterialien wie holz nicht die
alleinige lösung ja beton muss co2 frei
werden die bauforschung mit ausgeweitet
die digitalisierung building information
modeling wird ausgeweitet smart city
konzept kommt wir haben viele viele
punkte die in die zukunft zeigen und
jetzt werden wir noch den
regelungsrahmen angehen weil wir nicht
an zu den haushalt machen können und da
wird die ampel liefern das haben wir
beim lg gesetz gesehen beim wind an land
gesetzt mal wind auf 718 gesetzt und das
werden wir machen und dann werden wir
die probleme lösen und da brauche ich
keinen union die mir erzählt wie es geht
weil er hat 16 jahren
viele seiner kunden gelöst
sie können jetzt gleich antworten
zunächst hat das wort der kollege ulrich
lange cdu/csu-fraktion
[Applaus]
präsident liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
ja lieber kollege fest da war eine ganze
menge frust über die eigene regierung
jetzt gerade in der rede aber manchmal
muss einfach ein ventil raus und an den
seinem zumindest menschlich besser liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen eindreiviertel
jahre haben wir jetzt ein eigenes
bauministerium wir haben jetzt mit
diesem haushalt eine eigene handschrift
der ministerin erwartet wir haben eigene
ideen erwartet wir haben ein organigramm
erwartete schaut übrigens so aus im
internet nur damit jeder mal sieht wie
im internet das organigramm ausschaut
das sind ein paar strichmännchen
also liebe kolleginnen und kollegen es
geht darum das jetzt hier mehr als nur
angekündigt wird es geht darum liebe
ministerin dass dieses ministerium ins
arbeiten kommt nämlich nicht nur fragen
lieber kollege kurt holzbau versus
betonen nein wir werden beides brauchen
wo ist die angekündigte novelle des
baugesetzbuches große töne wir wissen
wie schwierig ja da braucht man nicht
lachen immer kollegen in aldrup wir
wissen wie schwierig da große töne
nichts gekommen bündnis für bezahlbares
wohnen groß angekündigt bisher nichts
neues
genossenschaftsanteile
2,6 millionen insgesamt was ist denn das
wirklich für eine finanzierung dass es
nicht dass es maximal so viel einstieg
aber da würde ich mich an ihrer stelle
nicht feiern lassen liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen
auf der anderen seite
haben sie das vertrauen der menschen
erschüttert derer die bauen wollen derer
die sanieren wollen derer die auf
klimaschutz gesetzt haben derer die auf
altersgerechten umbau gesetzt haben ob
es bereit sind 1 für habe oder 10 0 für
habig ist spielt doch keine rolle
liebe ministerin setzen sie sich endlich
im kabinett für die interessen der
bauwilligen ein machen sie trafen sie
planungssicherheit dass die menschen in
ihren vier wänden wirklich weiter
glücklich wohnen können
zu den energiekosten das ist natürlich
ein ganz großer als 40 zu lassen ein
ganz grosser witz an dieser stelle liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen der fdp mit der
vorwärts brille wir bräuchten mehr
angebot bei der energie und was haben
sie gestern beschlossen die akw
abzuschalten nicht mehr angebot sondern
weniger angebot wir haben gesagt
laufzeitverlängerung wir haben gesagt
die energie kosten müssen gesenkt werden
auf diese weise handeln sie für die
menschen frau ministerin haben auch sie
als bau ministerin im kabinett für
bezahlbaren wohnraum dankeschön
vielen dank herr kollege
nächster redner dass der kollege timo
schießen ob ski spd-fraktion
und timo schiesser noch ski sitzt auch
im ausschuss für stadtentwicklung
bauwesen und kommunen
na ja herr präsident werte kolleginnen
und kollegen seite damen und herren der
heute in erster lesung zur
beratungsstelle etatentwurf des
bundesbauministeriums ist ein guter und
gelungen damit ihm starten wir das bauen
und hohen unserm land verlässlich und
verantwortungsbewusst mit den
notwendigen finanziellen mitteln aus
dies ermöglicht auch im kommenden jahr
gesamtausgaben von 5 milliarden euro
davon allein für zukunftsinvestitionen
das bauen und wohnen
3,87 milliarden damit realisieren wir
mehr gutes bezahlbares wohnen und sorgen
so auch für soziale sicherheit in
unserem land und das allen gegenwärtigen
krisen zum trotz krisen die seine
regierungskoalition zuvor noch nie so
vielfach und so schwerwiegend zu
meistern hatte umso mehr danke im namen
der ganzen spd bundestagsfraktion der
ministerin klarer davids und ihre
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeitern im
neuen ministerium für ihre erfolgreich
geleistete arbeit für diesen entwurf
neben der richtigerweise massiv
gesteigerten förderung des sozialen
wohnungsbaus und den konstanten mitteln
für familien mit dem bau kindergeld
fehlt auch die städtebauförderung
erfreulicherweise
verlässlich und völlig zu recht zu den
wichtigsten einzelposten im etat
missionierten mitteln von insgesamt
knapp über einer million der euro eine
milliarde die auch weiterhin richtig und
wichtig ist weil die städtebauförderung
ein unverzichtbarer bestandteil
kommunaler stadtentwicklung ist noch
dazu löst jeder euro den wir in die
städtebauförderung geben zusätzliche
sieben euro private oder öffentliche bau
investitionen aus unterm strich entsteht
seine starke mehrere milliarden euro
schwere investitionsrunde die unseren
bürgerinnen und bürgern spürbar zugute
kommt spürbar ganz konkret in den
städten und gemeinden
inzwischen ist die städtebauförderung
ursprünglich vom damaligen bundeskanzler
willy brandt angestoßen eine über 50
jährige erfolgsgeschichte
und sie hat bis heute nichts an
aktualität verloren
vor meiner zeit als
bundestagsabgeordneter war ich beruflich
bei einer großen kommunale
wohnungsgesellschaft im ruhrgebiet tätig
und hier konnte ich immer wieder selbst
erfahren in einem quartier zu leben und
sich dort wohlzufühlen das ist viel mehr
als in den eigenen vier wänden zu wohnen
im idealfall geht guter bezahlbarer
wohnraum immer auch einher mit einem
attraktiven wohnumfeld und aus diesen
beruflichen hintergrund heraus weiß ich
was städtebauförderung praktisch vor ort
bedeutet insbesondere was sie alles
imstande ist zu leisten und zu
ermöglichen auch im sinne von mehr
nachhaltigkeit
der großen herausforderung unserer zeit
und folgerichtig sichern wir die
nachhaltigkeit in den wohnquartieren mit
gezielten förderprogramm nur
stichpunktartig seien ja genannt die
kommunale wärme planung lüftungs
schneisen gegen hitze versicherungs
flächen gegen hochwasser sowie urbane
grünflächen für erholung und gute luft
insgesamt legen wir als spd-fraktion
deshalb auch in dieser legislaturperiode
großen wert darauf dass wir die
erfolgsgeschichte der städtebauförderung
verlässlich fortführen und der
vorliegende italien fuhr stellt die
sicher gut so doch nicht nur
doch nicht nur aus meiner beruflichen
erfahrung auch aus meinen
nordrhein-westfälischen wahlkreis in
hagen und dem südlichen
ennepe-ruhr-kreis weiß ich wie wichtig
diese städtebauförderung programme für
die menschen vor ort sind so sind die
städte meines wahlkreises seit bestehen
des programms mehr als 40 millionen euro
städtebaufördermittel geflossen und
häufig in sozial benachteiligte
strukturschwache stadt und ortsteile die
dringend auf unsere hilfe angewiesen
sind und oftmals gelingt es auf diesem
weg erfreulicherweise dass die
städtebauförderung finanzschwache
kommunen wie meine heimatstadt tagen bei
der finanzierung nicht nur unterstützt
sondern sie ermöglicht überhaupt erst
etliche baumaßnahmen werte kolleginnen
und kollegen die haushaltsplanberatungen
gehen noch in die entscheidende phase
doch ein guter gelungener entwurf liegt
sowie exemplarisch ausgeführt vor
bundesbauministerium klara geywitz die
von unserem kanzler olaf scholz geführte
bundesregierung insgesamt und gemeinsam
mit ihnen allen voran wir als spd
bundestagsfraktion zusammen stark
schreiben wir das thema bauen und wohnen
mit nachdruck groß doch ganz
entscheidend
doch ganz entscheidend wir stellen hier
allen gegenwärtigen kriegen zum trotz
wie zuletzt erst am wochenende beim
großen entlastungspaket auch erfolgreich
und eindrucksvoll bewiesen wir stellen
ja für verlässlich und
verantwortungsbewusst die notwendigen
finanziellen mittel bereit die menschen
in unserem land sie können sich auf uns
verlassen wir packen das zusammen stark
an herzlichen dank
kinoshita noski hier zum etat des
bundesministeriums für wohnen dieser
etat dürfte sich aber doch noch stark
verändern unter anderem wegen der gerade
erst beschlossenen wohngeldreform
mit der ja zum beispiel der kreis der
wohngeldberechtigten auf zwei millionen
haushalte erweitert werden
meine damen und herren liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen der regierungsentwurf des
einzelnen 125 das bundesministerium für
wohnen stadtentwicklung bauwesen den wir
heute beraten umfasst ein volumen von
knapp über 5 milliarden euro der plafond
mit nach der mittelfristigen
finanzplanung auf 6,3 milliarden euro
bis 2026 ansteigen das ist eine
steigerung von mehr als 25 prozent
gegenüber dem entwurf für das kommende
jahr das sind enorme verpflichtungen für
die zukunft und dabei ist der vorgelegte
regierungsentwurf wahrlich ein entwurf
ein entwurf der auf tönernen füßen steht
von dem wir heute am beginn der beratung
noch überhaupt gar nicht wissen wo wir
am ende rauskommt beispiel im juli haben
das bundeswirtschaftsministerium und das
bundesbauministerium ein sofortprogramm
zur erreichung der klimaschutzziele im
gebäudesektor vorgestellt soweit sind
gut haushalterische abbildung noch
unklar das bundesbauministerium das
bundesfinanzministerium betreiben das
projekt reform des bundes aus das ist
auch mit guten projekt mitteln
ausgestattet in kürze frau ministerin
hat das gesagt sollen die ergebnisse
vorgelegt werden haushalterische
abbildung unklar und vor allen dingen
gibt es hier auch um personal und
personal ist sowieso ein gutes stichwort
sie schreiben selbst dass ich die
haushaltsansätze noch erhöhen werden
insbesondere weil das personal noch
nicht vollständig abgebildet ist es
fehlen noch mehr als 320 planstellen und
stellen die aus dem ehemaligen
bundesinnenministerium übertragen worden
und ganz aktuell nehmen wir das
entlastungspaket das dritte entlastungs
paket der bundesregierung stichwort
wohngeld
politisch kann man darüber streiten und
sicherlich sinnvoll aber das kostet
sicherlich mehrere hundert millionen
euro keiner weiß wo wir heute am ende
landen meine damen und herren ich kann
ja verstehen dass regierung auf aktuelle
entwicklungen
reagiert das ist auch gut und richtig so
aber wenn man dabei lange zögert und
zaudert sie streitet hin und her rudert
dann wird das auch mal enkel und dann
kann es nicht sein dass handwerkliche
dinge planbare dinge die man noch nicht
im haushalt des ressorts abgebildet sind
wie zum beispiel das thema stellen oder
wie zum beispiel das organigramm ich
kann nur bestätigen
militos haushälter auch nicht vor das
organigramm findet man auf der homepage
als strichmännchen zeichen meine damen
und herren das widerspricht prinzipien
wie transparenz wie haushaltsklarheit
haushaltswahrheit die leiden darunter
und die kontrolle läge
haushaltsgesetzgeber aber auch durch den
rechnungshof wird erschwert
zum haushalt in gemütliche art der
haushalt in der region hängt
wohnungsbauförderung umfasst diesem jahr
im regierungsentwurf
1,275 milliarden euro das ist der
politische schwerpunkt den frau
ministerin gesetzt hat und sie hält am
ziel jährlich 400.000 wohnungen davon
100.000 sozialwohnungen zu bauen fest
und aber das haben wir heute schon
mehrfach gehört ist dieses ziel leider
makulatur geworden wir erleben ein
einbruch der aufträge im wohnungsbau auf
16 prozent die zahl der baugenehmigung
die zurück und das betrifft eben nicht
nur den einheimischen wohnungsbau
sondern auch den geschosswohnungsbau
auch öffentliche bauträger geben
mittlerweile derartige projekte auf oder
verschieben sie ganz aktuell und
mittlerweile auf der anderen seite
können sich auch menschen aus der mitte
der gesellschaft das eigenheim nicht
mehr leisten und das liegt anja
explodierenden baukosten
materialengpässen fachkräfte meine
baulands mangel steigenden zinsen dem
förderkreis bei der kfw oder immer mehr
vorschriften und immer höheren standards
meine damen und herren darauf braucht es
eine antwort frau ministerin und eins
ist auch klar geld allein hilft da auch
nicht
ja es gibt eine reihe von möglichkeiten
in der tat eine ist er schon angekündigt
worden die abschreibungsregeln sollen
zur mitte nächsten jahres verbessert
werden dass es reichlich spät wir
brauchen aber schnellere
genehmigungsverfahren
wir brauchen eine harmonisierung von
bauvorschriften wir brauchen
vereinfachte regeln für bauen im bestand
wir brauchen weniger standards wir
müssen auch über das thema
grunderwerbsteuer reden in der teig mit
den ländern wir brauchen steuerliche
anreize wir brauchen programme wie jung
kauft alt und wir brauchen förderungen
für umnutzungen zum beispiel ehemaliger
gewerbe-immobilien
diese anstrengungen in diese richtung
müssen erhöht und der letzte punkt wäre
dafür tragen sie selbst schreiben in
puncto förderprogramme in ihren ampel
koalitionsvertrag wir werden unseren
einsatz für altersgerechtes wohnen und
barriere abbau verstärken und die mittel
für das kfw-programm
auskömmlich aufstocken jetzt schaut man
den haushaltsentwurf von ihnen für das
nächste jahr rein dann kürzen sie das
programm um 42 millionen euro ein und
nachdem sie bereits in diesem jahr nur
noch 105 millionen euro bereitgestellt
haben der topf in diesem jahr aktuell
schon leer ist meine damen und herren
das ist das gegenteil von einer
auskömmlichen finanzierung
und deshalb ist braucht mehr klarheit
und mehr verlässlichkeit mehr klarheit
bei dem stück zuständigkeiten zb bei den
förderprogrammen zwischen den ressorts
mehr klarheit beim thema bundesbau wer
hat denn da eigentlich sehr gut auf ist
es das bundesfinanzministerium ist das
bundesbauministerium wie sie die
organisationsstruktur aus wir brauchen
mehr klarheit bei ihren zielen lösen sie
konkurrierende ziele auf setzen sie klar
prioritäten und bei den förderprogrammen
gilt hin und her hilft nicht sie sehen
dass verunsicherung am baubereich
anrichten kann und deshalb brauchen wir
planungssicherheit und verlässlichkeit
und eine klare prioritätensetzung diesem
sinne dass es die messlatte für uns und
die kundenberatung ich freue mich drauf
sagt
markus ulmer dass damit der letzte
redner in dieser debatte zum einzelplan
25 bundesministerium für wohnen
stadtentwicklung und bauwesen